to understand Nvidia you've got to
understand its Mercurial founder Jensen
Wong was born in southern Taiwan in
February of 1963 when he was four years
old his father traveled to New York City
for work Jensen's father realized right
away that the family would have a better
future in America soon after Jensen's
father returned home his mother bought
an English dictionary every day she
would pick 10 words and grilled Jensen
and his older brother five years later
the family decided the time was right it
was time to move but they faced the
challenge that confronts almost every
prospective migrant they didn't have the
money Jensen's parents were desperate to
find him and his brother a good school
even if it meant delaying their own move
they finally found one that sounded like
it fit the bill Oneida Baptist College
in Eastern Kentucky Jensen would later
say that he and his brother were the
first foreigners to attend this school
and possibly the first people of Chinese
origin to ever set foot in the town of
Onida it turns out that there was a good
reason why this school was so cheap it
was isn't the prep school that Jensen's
parents were hoping to send their kids
to it was reform school for troubled
kids when Jensen arrived there as a
nine-year-old his roommate was a 17 year
old who'd been just released from prison
and was actually recovering from some
stab wounds it could have ended very
badly but Jensen showed an early glimmer
of the character trait that would come
to Define him where others saw adversity
he saw opportunity Jensen helped his
roommate with math in turn his roommate
introduced Jensen to weightlifting
Jensen spent a couple of years at onita
until his parents were finally able to
save up enough money to join him in the
United States after a little time in
Tacoma Washington the family settled in
Portland Jensen skipped two grades in
high school and went to Oregon State for
his undergrad he loved math so it was
only natural that he chose to study
electrical engineering after graduating
he moved to Silicon Valley together with
Laurie his wife and former Oregon State
lab partner it was the mid-1980s the era
of Top Gun and Wall Street it felt like
anything was possible Jensen joined AMD
to work on designing new Chips it was an
extremely interesting stage of the
company's life cycle in 1985 AMD made
the Fortune 500 list for the first time
but by later that year the American ship
Market was suffering a downturn this was
partly due to trade pressures from Japan
but it was also because the American
market for chips was bloated and
stagnant inspiration was in short supply
AMD wrote out the crisis by innovating
aggressively which included devising the
Liberty chip program a commitment to
design or manufacture a new chip or
chipset every week Jensen watched
closely and learned a lesson that would
stay with him for the rest of his career
if you're not looking for ways to
innovate and expand your mission you're
falling behind working at AMD in the
1980s meant working with the fastest
chips in the world one of Jensen's early
projects was working on a super fast one
megahertz CPU chip for comparison the
ryzen 7 amd's top of the line CPU today
has a clock speed of 3.4 gigahertz more
than 3 1000 times faster he quickly
realized a couple of things first
designing chips was really hard there
was good reason why at the time only
Intel and AMD could apply the financial
and intellectual Firepower to make it
happen at scale this led directly to
Jensen's second realization it wasn't as
cool as he had imagined at the time
designing chips was a highly manual
process and leading companies all use
their own internal full stack methods so
he began thinking about how to make the
process more cool and Cutting Edge maybe
he didn't fully grasp it at the time but
coolness was actually a great proxy for
other important things like a company's
speed of manufacturing ease of
replication and ability to attract
Talent Jensen began to believe that one
way to make designing chips cooler was
to encourage specialization that would
let them develop better tools and
methods thereby improving the quality of
the final products that thought which
was already percolating would become
even more urgent for Jensen when a
colleague left AMD for a star startup
called LSI logic LSI had just gone
public and made Sequoia Capital 135
million dollars which was at the time
the biggest ever one day return on an
IPO it was one of the first companies
making application specific integrated
circuits or Asics an Asic is a chip
designed for a specific technical
function rather than general purpose use
general purpose chipsets traded off
power and efficiency for versatility
that made sense for home and Enterprise
Computing but for companies that knew
exactly what they needed their chips to
do and needed to extract as much power
as possible it wasn't an ideal solution
more specific technical functions meant
that chips could be integrated into
Niche industry systems this enabled
companies like LSI logic to custom
designed chips without needing to own
the full stack Jensen realized this
aligned with his own thinking about how
chip design could be improved so when
LSI presented him with the opportunity
to join he jumped at it no sooner than
Jensen had got his feet under his desk
he was assigned find one of lsi's
biggest customers Sun Microsystems he
helped build chips for what became their
first major workstation product the
spark station one this collaboration
would Define Jensen's first few years at
LSI he worked directly with Sun's
co-founders Andy bechtelsheim and with
vinod khosla today bechtelsheim and
kosla are legendary Venture capitalists
back then they were simply world-class
engineers and businessmen Jensen built a
reputation as a rising star he was
creative charismatic and a great Builder
let's fast forward to late 1992. Jensen
had just finished his Masters eight
years after he started it he was still
at LSI then he was approached by two Sun
Engineers Chris malikowski and Curtis
Prime after years of working with Jensen
they trusted him they told him that they
weren't loving life at Sun and asked if
he had the time to discuss an idea they
met at one of Jensen's favorite spots
Denny's demand for 3D Graphics is
increasing Chris and Curtis began we are
great chip Engineers you're a great chip
product manager how about we make a chip
that can enable a PC to handle 3D
Graphics by taking some of the workload
off the CPU there was definitely a bold
case for the idea that they were
pitching all the early evidence
suggested the consumers loved Advanced
Graphics Wolfenstein 3D was released in
May of 1992 by 1995 it had sold a
quarter of a million copies Doom came
out in 1993 and took the World by storm
Jurassic Park was one of the first
Hollywood movies that made extensive use
of 3D Graphics it made a billion dollars
at the box office but there were lots of
risks the technology was very new and
very expensive you weren't only making a
bet on consumers wanting games with 3D
Graphics you were also making a bet on
gaming becoming a lucrative industry
which if you were making chips wasn't
something that you had all that much
control over it was risky but Jensen had
already shown his Flair for turning
risks into opportunities he said yes to
Chris and Curtis's pitch they were all
in that dinner at Denny's would prove to
be one of the most important meals and
the best investment of their lives
Jensen went to the CEO of LSi logic a
guy named wolf Corrigan to Tender his
resignation wilf asked Jensen some
pointed questions who's going to use
these graphics cards who makes PC games
what's the developer ecosystem like
prior to his role at LSI logic wolf had
been the CEO of Fairchild semiconductor
he knew what he was talking about he
must have liked Jensen's answers because
he offered Jensen and his co-founders an
introduction to the most legendary
venture capitalist in the world Don
Valentine so Jensen went to see Don and
totally botched his pitch it was a
disaster Jensen was nervous unprepared
intimidated by the man sitting across
from him he was getting ready to leave
when Don stopped him and said okay that
wasn't very good but wilf advised me to
give you money so that's what I'm gonna
do what's the lesson here well it's not
that you can afford to be Cavalier about
VC pitches it's the Jensen's pitch was
much more than the hour that he had
spent with Don Valentine it was the
culmination of an eight-year process
sure he didn't stick The Landing but
he'd already done enough throughout his
career to deeply impress someone of the
caliber of will Corgan every day when
Jensen demonstrated his knowledge and
earned the trust of his colleagues and
superiors he was making an investment it
just took until that moment for the
investment to truly pay off Sequoia took
part in a two million dollar round that
valued the new company at six million
dollars The Next Step was deciding on a
name inspiration came from the file
naming protocols that Jensen and his
co-founders were using they'd been
saving designs as dot NV files which
stood for next version The Next Step
they took was to look in the dictionary
for words with that pair of letters they
found a Latin word Nvidia which means
Envy great they decided it was time to
become the Envy of the industry Nvidia
had seed funding it had a name it was
time to define a purpose and build a
business model Jensen saw that gaming
had the potential to become the best way
to tell stories because unlike movies or
TV games weren't pre-recorded the
outcomes weren't predetermined they
could be different every time you played
them but he also understood that
technology was simply not not mature
enough to realize that potential that
led him to Define nvidia's purpose to
enable Graphics to be a new medium to
tell stories in order to build their
business model the Nvidia team needed to
convince developers of 2D games to learn
how to develop 3D games that required
the development of new apis and
Frameworks that could accommodate the
new graphics chip Nvidia was promising
there weren't many of them around at the
time it was a tough sell partly because
there just weren't many developers that
were ready for that kind of Step Up and
partly it was because Nvidia had no
track record but remember it was backed
by Sequoia that carried enough weight to
land a deal with one of the leading
gaming companies of the mid-1990s Sega
the two companies began working together
but Nvidia made a big blunder right out
of the gate when creating 3D Graphics
you need to set what's called a
geometric primitive A Primitive is the
atomic unit of Graphics it's the
simplest shape the system can render the
earliest graphic systems had the most
basic Primitives points and lines Nvidia
and Sega chose to Define quadrilateral
four-sided polygons as their Primitives
that would become a real problem as the
industry matured other companies began
realizing that kids wanted to play games
on their pcs one of those companies just
happened to develop the dominant
operating system Microsoft wanted to
encourage the development of 3D Graphics
directly onto windows that also meant
cutting out the middleman Nvidia
Microsoft called its new product direct
3D we know it is DirectX today direct 3D
used triangles as its geometric
primitive in hindsight it's easy to see
why as the most basic shape that enables
the creation of any kind of curved
surface triangles are the building
blocks of 3D Graphics they quickly
became the industry standard so much so
that nvidia's headquarters today is
literally made out of triangles as an
homage to game developers other
companies and other developers did the
sensible thing and joined the Microsoft
ecosystem at the time not doing so would
have been risky Nvidia had been working
on what they thought would become the
chip underpinning the Dreamcast then
Sega dropped a bombshell they were
walking away what's more or is that in
the 18 months since Nvidia started
working on this chip the price of memory
had gone down by about half nvidia's
competitors were designing their chips
later and adding more memory at lower
cost they were benefiting from Moore's
Law the famous observation made by
Gordon Moore that the number of
transistors on an integrated circuit
doubles approximately every 18 months
they were also benefiting from the fact
that they were followers not first
movers being a first mover is great if
you can Define the product and establish
consumer expectations but if your
product isn't perfect your Rivals will
learn from your mistakes having lost
their main customer and video was
hemorrhaging cash fast it now had about
nine months of Runway left most normal
Founders would have admitted defeat and
pulled the plug but Jensen wasn't ready
for defeat Jensen knew that there was
one more thing that Nvidia could do to
stay alive it required laying off all
but about 35 Staff members those who
remained had a crystal clear brief to
design from scratch and ship a new chip
before they ran out of Runway needless
to say that was impossible or at least
it was according to the principles which
governed chip design in the mid 90s
remember how I said earlier that
nvidia's Rivals were one-upping it by
shipping chips with more memory at lower
cost thereby exploiting Moore's Law well
Jensen was about to flip the script if
Nvidia couldn't benefit from Moore's Law
it would have to get around it instead
the basic idea was this comprehensive
verification of Chip design is crucial
to reducing development costs and
timelines the functional verification of
a chip design is usually performed with
logic simulation or physical prototyping
on what's called field programmable gate
arrays or fpgas Jensen knew that
physical prototyping had a few drawbacks
firstly the process required to
implement a large design into several of
these gate arrays could be long and
arduous secondly it made fixing design
flaws time consuming therefore Jensen
recognized an inefficiency simulation
was underutilized early in the
verification process when bugs were more
frequent The Next Step was finding a way
to exploit it he'd heard about new
software that enabled the emulation of
chips the startup that produced the
software was unproven though but Jensen
thought it could still do what he needed
besides he was out of options it was one
minute to midnight it was time to bet
every dollar Nvidia had left in the bank
on black All or Nothing it came up black
emulation allowed Nvidia to circumvent
established production and shipping
Cycles what previously took 18 to 24
months was suddenly possible in six the
result was the Riva 128 one of the first
consumer graphics cards to integrate 3D
acceleration in addition to traditional
2D and video acceleration almost
overnight it became much easier for
NVIDIA to persuade developers to use its
chips why because Jensen had identified
and optimized for a fundamental
principle of customer Behavior the
perception that performance was King
sure his process contained some
imperfections but by radically
compressing its design cycle Nvidia was
able to make big leaps every six months
it could learn by doing and make step
changes in the quality and
sophistication of its chipsets twice or
even three times as often as its Rivals
there's a real lesson there if you
believe you can anticipate or shape
consumer demand run as fast as you can
toward that goal by about 1997 the
Nvidia team was doubling the performance
they were delivering for a given price
every six months they'd hacked Moore's
law to run at 3x speed a few years later
they would help thousands of companies
and researchers do something very
similar more on that later though by
1999 Nvidia had moved two generations
beyond the Riva 128 with the Riva TNT
and the Riva tnt2 Jensen and the team
were Keen to find a new name for the
successor to the tnt2 so they held a
contest called name that chip there were
over 12 000 entries you might have heard
of the winner GeForce the first ever
GeForce was the 256 which shipped in
1999. it provided up to a 50 or greater
Improvement in frame rate in some games
compared to its main competitor products
gen called it the first GPU a graphics
Processing Unit A lot of people at the
time dismissed that as a nice piece of
marketing but he was right most people
just couldn't see it and in fact the
development of gpus came just in time
the performance increase of CPUs had
slowed to as little as 10 every year as
chip makers encountered physical
constraints including size yield and
heat limits with the development of the
GPU Nvidia had once again outsmarted
Moore's law to understand more we need
to dig into a concept called parallel
Computing a very basic model of a
standard CPU is that you run an
instruction and then the CPU executes a
long chain of operations to process
whatever it is you want to Output this
chain is sequential one thing has to
happen after another in a specific order
that's not true for graphics processing
Graphics can be rendered in parallel
because pixels on a screen can be
rendered independently of each other
therefore the only real constraint on
how quickly you could process Graphics
was how quickly you could execute
instructions in parallel raw computing
power the more cores you add to a system
the more quickly you can execute those
parallel functions beginning with the G4
series Nvidia leveraged that parallelism
but it would still take years for use
cases Beyond gaming and Graphics to
emerge more on that later before any of
that happened Jensen Curtis and Chris
decided that Nvidia was ready to go
public the company first sold shares to
the public on January 22nd 1999 at 12 a
share and a 600 million dollar valuation
if you had spent ten thousand dollars at
the IPO you could have bought 833 shares
of Nvidia once you factor in the four
stock splits since their listing the
value of that stock would have peaked in
December of 2021 at over 13 million
dollars not bad for a ten thousand
dollar investment the massively
successful IPO was a milestone for
Jensen Curtis and Chris not to mention
Don Valentine and Sequoia Nvidia was
suddenly flush with capital their IPO
and the development of the G4 series
also meant they had lots of another
precious commodity credibility Microsoft
approached Nvidia about applying the GPU
capability for a secret new project it
was working on can you guess the secret
project that Microsoft was working on
around the turn of the Millennium that
required Advanced Graphics it wasn't the
Zone Microsoft and Nvidia shook hands on
a 500 million dollar deal for NVIDIA to
supply graphics for the Xbox the chip
Nvidia used was the modified version of
its newest design the GeForce 3. this
was the first card to contain
programmable shaders and lighting
earlier graphics cards were basically
fixed function Graphics accelerators
they would be able to map textures onto
a set of polygons but the output was
predetermined programmable lighting and
shading meant Dynamic lighting and
shading the GeForce 3 enabled developers
to deliver a much more complete gaming
experience it was a big step forward for
GPU architecture and it was the fullest
realization yet of what Jensen promised
Nvidia would do unlock a new way to tell
stories the Xbox deal and G4 series put
Nvidia on an incredible growth
trajectory for the fiscal year ending
January 31st 1999 the company made a
hundred 158 million dollars in Revenue
they more than doubled that the
following year to 375 million the year
after that
735 million the next year which was when
the Xbox was released Nvidia made about
1.4 billion in Revenue doubling doubling
doubling year after year exponential
growth is the pathway to becoming one of
the biggest companies in the world
financial success was made possible by
technological success as I said earlier
Nvidia had effectively doubled or even
tripled how quickly they were able to
ship new chipsets they shipped their
first GeForce card to 256 in October of
1999. its successor the GeForce 2
shipped the following spring the GeForce
2 ultra shipped in late 2000 the GeForce
3 with its programmable shaders shipped
in Spring of 2001 and then six months
later the GeForce 3 ti-500 Jensen
started Nvidia because he knew there was
a better way to make chips within a
decade he had totally proved his point
Nvidia had created a truly programmable
GPU that took Graphics to the next level
and allow developers and designers to
tell new kinds of stories Nvidia had
risen to the top of the industry it had
near perfect product Market fit and yet
Jensen knew as well as anyone that if
you don't continue aggressively
innovating you're moving backwards by
the middle of the 2000s some clouds were
gathering on the horizon gross margins
were getting thinner the original Xbox
was about to be replaced by its
successor the Xbox 360 which was not
powered by an Nvidia GPU that meant
another long-term Revenue stream was
about to run dry nvidia's biggest Rivals
were getting increasingly serious in
2006 Intel announced Lara B its own
dedicated GPU don't get me wrong the
picture wasn't as Bleak as it had been
10 years earlier before Nvidia pioneered
chip emulation they were still
extracting huge revenues from PC gaming
but Jensen wasn't the type of guy to be
satisfied with dominating a single
Market he wanted to be ready for when
gpus could be used in other domains
could Nvidia reinvent itself yet again
could Jensen come up with yet another
genius play we're about to find out the
story of how Nvidia went from being a
leader in building graphics cards for
gaming into the world's eighth biggest
company begins with a story that can't
entirely be verified supposedly in the
early 2000s a quantum chemistry
researcher at Stanford called Jensen to
say thanks for solving a problem it
apparently took up to two weeks for this
researcher's machine to do important
computations until that is the
researcher's son suggested that he go to
his local electronics store buy a bunch
of GeForce cards and install them on his
lab computers that's what he did and
apparently the computations that used to
take days or even weeks on his lab
machine could now be completed in mere
hours the researcher ran the same
computations on his old setup which was
basically a supercomputer to double
check that the results held up they did
but on the rig of Nvidia gpus they
finished 10 times faster in truth
whether this happened or not is kind of
beside the point what matters is that it
motivated Jensen to evolve Nvidia into a
new kind of company do you remember what
inspired Jensen Curtis and Chris to
start in video in the first place it was
their desire to enable a new way to tell
stories on one front they'd already
succeeded Nvidia was a huge factor in
games becoming deeper more immersive and
more entertaining but there was nothing
specifically about gaming that made it
nvidia's main source of Revenue Beyond
being the most obvious use case when it
began developing its chips there were
still so many stories to tell and
discoveries to make Jensen wanted Nvidia
to help people like that Stanford
researcher discover new insights so he
was about to make his biggest and
boldest bet yet on scientific Computing
his first step was to ask the first
order question that everyone should ask
before making such a big bet how big is
the addressable Market that's the
question that Don Valentine at Sequoia
would have been asking at the time it
was kind of hard to argue that there was
a sufficiently big opportunity the
customers would mostly be universities
or individual researchers in
science-specific domains looking for
ways to perform faster computations
they'd be working on hard problems like
computational modeling and Drug
Discovery maybe the market could be
expanded to other Professional Services
like architecture but it was still
difficult to see the use case that would
Merit such a big outlay being Visionary
means seeing things others can't but the
most Visionary Founders are also often
the most stubborn I'm sure Jensen did
market research to understand the
potential of scientific Computing but
it's also clear he just fell in love
with the concept he wanted to develop
Hardware that would enable smart people
to expand the frontiers of human
knowledge and tell new kinds of stories
he was confident that Innovation would
increase the number of viable use cases
for scientific Computing and he was
confident that his play was the path to
nvidia's durable differentiation you've
heard the saying that if you build it
they will come but Jensen was more
interested in the opposite his attitude
was if you don't build it they can't
come that was his way of articulating
something really key the best way to
generate massive revenues is to create
new markets after ascertaining the size
of the addressable Market the next
question to always ask no matter your
size is what will it take to get where
you want to go if in video idea was to
capture the market that Jensen believed
would soon emerge it had to be ready it
had to provide a new kind of
technological platform one that would
rival the invention of the transistor
for how it transformed Computing when
Nvidia debuted the G4 Series in the late
90s Jensen called it the first GPU
remember that the g-force did something
new it allowed for parallel execution of
Graphics processing tasks in practice
that meant faster and more Dynamic
rendering of Graphics supporting those
functions required Nvidia to extend the
C programming language to provide
developers with new tools their
extension of C was called CG C for
graphics it was a high level shading
language developed by Nvidia in close
collaboration with Microsoft for
programming vertex and pixel shaders
it's kind of like an instructional
pamphlet for the next generation of
Graphics but to achieve Jensen's true
goals he needed more than a pamphlet he
needed a full stack API that could be
harnessed by developers and users in
other domains he found the answer in a
researcher named Ian buck in 2003 e Ian
led a team which developed Brook the
first widely adopted programming model
to extend C with data parallel
constructs by 2006 Ian had joined Nvidia
together they got to work on a general
purpose parallel Computing platform
which could Leverage The Parallel
Computing capabilities of nvidia's gpus
to solve highly complex computational
problems like the one facing our friend
the Stanford Quantum chemist the result
was Cuda compute unified device
architecture version 1.0 shipped in
November of 2006. it was the skeleton
key that unlocked A Whole New World many
scientific and AI workloads have
inherent massive parallelism in their
algorithms and because of that they run
very slowly on CPUs Cuda was able to
offload those complex and time-consuming
functions to run on gpus exploiting
their parallel capabilities all of a
sudden developers could tap into
incredible computational power to
dramatically accelerate workloads in
domains as varied as computational
Finance fluid dynamics whether
forecasting Medical Imaging quantum
chemistry electromagnetics and more if
the invention of the transistor and
microprocessor are recognized as the
greatest inventions in Computing then
Cuda can't be that far behind and would
you believe the technical feat wasn't
even the most extraordinary part of this
the most amazing part of Cuda was the
business model to start Nvidia has never
charged a dollar for it but it can only
be deployed on nvidia's Hardware this
idea might remind you of another huge
technology company that built a
brilliant development ecosystem which
was proprietary to its expensive
first-in-class Hardware of course I'm
talking about Apple but what's
incredible is that Jensen started on
this journey before iOS before the
iPhone there's a beautiful symmetry
there gpus unlock the power of parallel
Computing an apple and Nvidia created
the business models that made them
billions of dollars in parallel but even
the progress of this new development
platform and an equally elegant business
model weren't enough to put it on the
path it is on today in fact nvidia's
stock actually went down by around 50 in
2011 after the company missed its
earnings Targets in a way Cuda was
invented before the rest of the world
was ready it would take a twist of fate
for it to catch up in the year 2000 an
American Computer Science Professor
named fei-fei Lee began working on an
image classifying project she called
imagenet she was inspired by a project
at Princeton from the 1980s called
wordnat her aim was to create a database
of millions of correctly labeled images
to assist in AI image recognition once
the database was up and running she
decided to start a competition so that
other researchers could explore it and
use it in 2012 a team from the
University of Toronto made up of Alex
krashevsky Ilya sutsgiver and Jeffrey
Hinton won the competition they didn't
just win by a little though they
dominated the algorithm they submitted
which they called alexnet recognized
about 85 percent of the images it was
presented with as you might be able to
tell from its name Alex net was a neural
network deep learning neural networks
weren't new they'd been around for
decade kids but they were very
computationally demanding it was
basically impossible to harness them for
practical applications within a
traditional Computing architecture the
team from the University of Toronto did
exactly what you've already realized
they trained their neural network in
Cuda on Nvidia gpus this was the Big
Bang moment for artificial intelligence
the marriage of unprecedented parallel
computing power with deep learning
models that taught machines how to learn
it was cuda's killer app it's perfect
use case and it was also a huge
coincidence but as Jensen says it wasn't
a coincidence that Nvidia was the
company that benefited most from the
application of deep neural networks to
gpus because it had done the years of
work to Pioneer gpus in the first place
Nvidia made itself the hardware supplier
of choice for the machine learning
Revolution by being ready for the
opportunity when it came machine
learning transformed nvidia's business
by enabling entirely new revenue streams
one of them was broadening the customer
base for its high-end gpus like the RTX
3090 that includes Gamers researchers
and people who just want top of the line
processing power but the real money was
always going to be found in Enterprise
customers they have the deepest pockets
and the greatest need today top of the
line Nvidia gpus power thousands of
massive data centers for the world's
biggest Enterprise customers Google
Microsoft Amazon the biggest technology
companies in the world companies that
create and maintain the infrastructure
of the internet itself use Nvidia
Hardware when Tesla announced its Dojo
AI Training Center they announced their
intention to develop their own chips
internally but today it still uses
Nvidia chips think about that one
customer using chips for a single
purpose netted Nvidia at least 50
million dollars of Revenue Enterprise
definitively answers the question that
wolf Corrigan and Don Valentine asked
Jensen how big is this Market the market
is gigantic and growing in size every
day as some of the world's biggest and
most ambitious companies invest in deep
learning techniques to fight disease
build the next generation of autonomous
vehicles and revolutionize the Natural
Sciences there's a very good chance
they're doing so with Nvidia use there
was no looking back in April 2020 Nvidia
spent seven billion dollars to acquire
melanox a Next Generation networking
company since then it's tripled the
revenue generated by his data center
stream that's allowed Nvidia to pull off
the sort of Revenue growth that usually
only hot startups can enjoy in 2020
Nvidia announced it had generated about
11 billion dollars in Revenue over the
previous fiscal year last year that
figure jumped to 16.6 billion and in
February of 2020 Nvidia announced it had
generated an insane 26.9 billion dollars
in Revenue that's 60 increase from the
previous year for a 30 year old company
remember the business model an open
development ecosystem that can be
deployed only on Nvidia Hardware Cuda
and Nvidia gpus dominate several
application areas including deep
learning and underpin some of the
fastest computers in the world Nvidia
generates 8 billion dollars of free cash
flow every year and has more than 20
billion on hand whereas at the turn of
the 90s they had a 30 gross margin today
their margin sits at 66 percent they
have built and fortified one of the
world's deepest moats I want to talk
briefly about power and how companies
can wield it one common form of power is
the ability to choose where you operate
on the price curve that kind of power is
usually reserved for monopolies another
form of power is the ability to make
your competitors react to you rather
than the other way around that kind of
power is reserved for companies that
create new technologies in New Markets
it's very rare to wield both forms of
power let alone at the same time but
that's just what Nvidia was able to
accomplish by pioneering the emulation
of Graphics chips it could deliver cost
customers what they cared about most
sheer performance by creating truly
programmable gpus it leveraged parallel
architectures to massively accelerate
performance and just as the revenue from
that established technology was
beginning to Plateau it found a new use
case for its technology in the form of
enabling huge advances in machine
learning all while locking in consumers
and Enterprise customers into a
proprietary ecosystem that's real power
no one can predict the future but as
long as Jensen is in the driver's seat
Nvidia will never stop innovating
they're making a play for automotive
meaning the electric vehicle and
autonomous vehicle software stack Jensen
thinks that's a 300 billion addressable
market and another project with massive
potential is nvidia's Omniverse the
Omniverse isn't like the metaverse it's
not a place where you can walk around
commute to work or speculate on digital
property it's useful here to look at
Earth too the supercomputer project
Nvidia announced in late 2021. Earth 2
will combine GPU accelerated Computing
deep learning and observed and modeled
data to simulate ultra high res
resolution climate models in a world
where one-to-one scale simulations are
possible it's easy to imagine any
company simulating how their new product
or service will work in the Omniverse
before deploying it in the real world it
could be running the world's most
sophisticated climate models on a
replica digital Earth or space startups
simulating atmospheric effects or their
prototype vehicles or new pharmaceutical
firms finding hundreds of new molecules
that could hold the key to curing some
of the world's most persistent and
devastating diseases if the technology
is there then there's no limit the
Omniverse is an extremely ambitious
concept because nothing like it has ever
really existed but in a way it's easier
to see it working out partly that's down
to Jensen's unbelievable track record of
delivering moonshots but it's also
because it's easier to see the
continuity between the Omniverse and the
immense scientific discovery Nvidia has
enabled through Cuda Jensen of course
saw the potential of simulation from a
long way off in 2006 Nvidia invested in
a company that was creating a navigable
software model of the Earth back then it
was called Keyhole but today we know it
is Google Earth simulation holds in
incredible promise for accelerating
scientific discovery by an order of
magnitude one of the biggest reasons why
is that simulation already saved Nvidia
it's what enabled it to defy Moore's Law
and Pioneer chip emulation it was
critical to the development of the first
consumer gpus and it is the principal
underlying Cuda but most of all nvidia's
Extraordinary capacity for simulation
has allowed millions of people to do
what Jensen Wong promised when he
started the company 30 years ago tell
better stories thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed this video and if you'd
like to go a bit deeper please just
watch this video next